in Hong Kong anti Beijing demonstrators
are gearing up for another round of
protests just days before China
celebrates 70 years of communist rule
the riots which were sparked by a
controversial extradition bill last June
are now entering their 17th consecutive
week CB s foreign correspondent rainy
and Ascencio is in Hong Kong with the
latest
Raymie good morning good morning
pro-democracy demonstrators are now
gathering at Hong Kong's
tame our Park to commemorate the fifth
anniversary of the so called umbrella
revolution that was a massive
pro-democracy movement that lasted for
79 days back in 2014 the simmering
violent scene in the past few weeks
seems to have subsided but the message
is still very strong you might even be
able to hear the unofficial democracy
anthem of the protest movement right
beside me being blare nearby called
glory to Hong Kong now on Friday
thousands of people rallied near the
harbour holding signs demanding
political reform while chanting slogans
accusing the police of using brutal
force to suppress demonstrators their
message is clearly directed to Hong
Kong's central government and its
embattled leader Carrie Lam who are now
set on a course of damage control to
mend the city's reputation it's also
directed at Beijing which supports this
government this October first the
People's Republic of China celebrates
the 70th anniversary of its founding on
Thursday at LOM came face-to-face with
angry Hong Kong residents at a town hall
meeting and while she stress at the
controversial extradition bill that
sparked the protests had been cancelled
protesters have four more demands and
that includes universal suffrage but
this morning's large credibility took
another hit when the South China Morning
Post reported that Lam had asked Chinese
President Xi Jinping for approval before
that bill could be officially cancelled
earlier today
Joshua Wong who was a standout leader in
the original movement said that he would
run for election this November in a
press conference he also said if the
government would bar him from doing so
he's Pro
would continue for CBS this morning
Saturday rainy Inocencio Hong Kong